foreign
this is a story about failure my failure
and though the story has some kind of a
happy ending it's not your typical story
where failure is a stepping stone to
success it almost feels like failure is
celebrated a lot these days for instance
you hear slogans like fail forward fail
better fail faster and to be honest
these slogans drive me crazy I mean who
wants to fail failure is not fun and I
would know because you know I'm sort of
a poster child for failure in fact when
one of my friends was writing a book
about the topic he reached out to me to
write a chapter for his book
but I'm also an educational designer so
I see failure in terms of systems and
values that failure is often a
misalignment of values or bad design but
I'm getting ahead of myself
let me take you back to this point of my
failure
so I want to take you back to my
undergraduate days my freshman year in
engineering I'm sitting in a physics
class I'm looking forward to learning
and in my notes I'm writing little
limericks and poems about Quantum states
that tells you something about who I was
when I was that age I loved physics and
math but I also love art and literature
and poetry and film and I was excited
and engaged to be in this engineering
school
sadly that was not the case sadly for
those next four years were possibly the
worst four years of my life
creativity and Imagination was not
encouraged all we had was lectures upon
lectures and tests and tests and tests
there was no scope for understanding
there was no space for having fun with
the ideas
and these poems I was writing they were
I'm sure not great poetry but they were
meaningful to me they were a way for me
to explore and play with ideas something
that was squelched very early on and so
this went on for four years and I
finally graduated but I never genuinely
became an engineer I felt I was
worthless that I had failed and what was
sad was it was not a One-Shot failure it
was every day every month semester after
semester for four long years
and at this point I saw a poster for a
program in Visual Communications and on
a whim I decided to apply clearly I was
not going to be an engineer or a
scientist so maybe maybe I could make
educational film because I had grown up
inspired by people like Carl Sagan and
Jacob bronowsky long story short I got
into the program and almost overnight my
life changed
the system and structure and culture of
the institution were very different
creativity was encouraged flexibility
and playing with ideas was supported so
even these things that I this haphazard
things that had been interested in
dabbling with Art and Science and poetry
somehow were meaningful all of a sudden
and it was also there that was
introduced to the idea of design
something I didn't know much about but I
felt very much at home in for four years
in engineering I have never felt that
I'd become an engineer I had never felt
like I belonged but somehow this design
seemed to give me a purpose and meaning
and what was amazing was how quick that
change was
you know in May of that year I was
feeling worthless as if I was a failure
and by September of that same year I had
found a purpose I had found a community
I had found a field that I could live
within so even today I call myself an
educational designer and what that made
me realize is that my success or failure
depended on a variety of systems and
values that were often hidden from me
and this lens of design then allowed me
to look at the world that's something
that had been made up and that made me
question what are the other things that
we have made up well one of the biggest
things we have made up is this idea of
school there's nothing natural about
schools and universities you know
there's nothing natural about credit
hours and multiple choice exams and so
on
but underlying them are a certain key
values about what is worth learning and
what is not so this has led me to the
work that I do today
designed learner-centered just in
Equitable systems that question these
assumptions that we have made about how
learning should and can happen
now how does that work so let me give
you a story a few years back a local
school district reached out to us to
help them design a school for the future
now that's a tall order what does that
even mean how did we go about doing it
well first we created a design team an
Eclectic collection of teachers
administrators parents members of the
community
and then we set out to listen so we
talked to the Chambers of Commerce we
created focus groups we talked to parent
groups
and most importantly all through this we
kept asking ourselves who is at the
table and who is not and how could we
bring those who were not into the
conversation for instance one broke that
we never talk to or very rarely talk to
our children which is very strange given
that they are the ones who are going to
actually be in these schools so we talk
to kids lots of them we in fact followed
them for a day you know sitting in their
classes listening to lectures doing
worksheets eating cafeteria food
and really enjoying the joy of recess
and while we were doing this and
listening we kept asking ourselves
questions what were we seeing what does
this mean and we began to question
assumptions like why do why are things a
certain way how might we create a school
that actually connects with the
community how might we think of
technology in ways that allow for
expression and creativity
how might we create a school where which
is driven by the impulses of the learner
how might we create a school where we
break the one teacher one classroom
model
and in these conversations we began we
developed a set of design principles a
set of values that would guide our
discussions and our design these were
things that as a community we believed
in
and it was at this point in time where
things seemed to go a little slow where
we had so many possibilities but yet
they seemed like very few
and we wondered what the next step
forward would be and there were all
kinds of the usual hassles of Internet
failures and scheduling problems
but then chance happen we learned about
this building which was somewhat unused
in the school district that they said we
could play with
and suddenly the whole design team was
energized and if there's a lesson here
it is that you need to be prepared and
if opportunity comes your way you grab
it with both hands and don't let go and
that's exactly what we did all the work
we had done with the focus groups and
the design principles and so on came
together in this school and over two
years of work later this school exists
today it is a school that reflects the
values of the community
it's a school that's very different from
the ones that you see around you
we had to break down both literally and
figuratively a whole bunch of walls to
create this space where 100 plus kids
would learn and work together it is a
space where they're surrounded by an
array of responsible adults
who work in teams working in small
groups and large to meet the needs of
these Learners it is a school which is
open to the community both in its
demographics as well as allowing parents
and community members to go in and out
as and when needed
this is truly a special place
and that doesn't mean that we have
figured everything out but I am proud to
say that that school has expanded it
went in the next year to another Studio
space and then now it goes all the way
from k through eight
and for my team this is truly one of our
greatest successes to Circle back to the
beginning
you know one could argue that it was
that failure that led to this success
but I think that would be missing the
point it would be missing the point
because it ignores the pain and hurt
that failure causes it ignores the agony
that I went through for four long years
at that point when I graduated from
undergraduate degree I felt I had failed
I did not blame the system but now when
I look at it I realize maybe it was a
system that had failed me
A system that fails a lot of our
children focusing on the individual
prevents us from looking deeper it
prevents us from questioning the systems
that led to the failure it prevents us
from questioning the values that
underlie these systems we can and must
do better I think our children deserve
better that 18 year old me writing
poetry in physics class deserve better
thank you